>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TUCKER,
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
WHAT A GREAT DAY THIS HAS
BEEN.
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PARTIAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI, SHE WAS ALL
SET TO LEAVE ON A JET PLANE.
WELL, ACTUALLY A U.S.
MILITARY PLANE ON YOUR DIME
EMBARK ON A 7-DAY EXCURSION
WITH OTHER DEMOCRATIC
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THAT IS UNTIL PRESIDENT
TRUMP PULLED THE PLUG IN A
LETTER.
THE PRESIDENT WROTE NANCY
PELOSI DUE TO THE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN I'M SO SORRY
CONTINUE TO FORM THAT YOU
YOUR TRIP TO BRUSSELS AND
EGYPT AND AFGHANISTAN HAS
BEEN POSTPONED.
WE WILL RESCHEDULE THIS
7-DAY EXCURSION WHEN THE
SHUTDOWN IS OVER.
IN LIGHT THE 800,000 GREAT
AMERICAN WORKERS NOT
RECEIVING PAY, I'M SURE YOU
WOULD AGREE THAT POSTPONING
THIS PUBLIC RELATIONS EVENT
IS TOTALLY APPROPRIATE.
I ALSO FEEL THAT DURING THIS
PERIOD IT WOULD BE BETTER IF
YOU WERE IN WASHINGTON
NEGOTIATING WITH ME AND
JOINING THE STRONG BORDER
SECURITY MOVEMENT TO END THE
SHUTDOWN.
OBVIOUSLY IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE YOUR JOURNEY BY
FLYING COMMERCIAL, WELL,
THAT WOULD CERTAINLY BE YOUR
PREROGATIVE.
I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING YOU
SOON AND EVEN MORE FORWARD
TO WATCHING OUR OPEN AND
DANGEROUS SOUTHERN BORDER
FINALLY RECEIVE THE
ATTENTION, FUNDING, AND THE
SECURITY IT SO DESPERATELY
DESERVES.
AND KEEP IN MIND THIS LETTER
COMES ROUGHLY 24 HOURS AFTER
SPEAKER PELOSI CALLED FOR
THE STATE OF THE UNION TO BE
CANCELLED BECAUSE OF SOME
PHANTOM, IT TURNS OUT,
CONCERNS ABOUT INADEQUATE
SECURITY DUE TO THE ONGOING
SHUTDOWN.
OF COURSE, WE NOW DISCOVER
NANCY PELOSI NEVER EVER, NOT
ONCE, REACHED OUT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY OR THE SECRET
SERVICE BEFORE MAKING THAT
ANNOUNCEMENT.
NOW, BOTH DEPARTMENTS HAVE
LONG BEEN PLANNING FOR THE
JOINT ADDRESS, THEY WERE
FULLY PREPARED AND NANCY
PELOSI MADE UP THOSE
CONCERNS.
WHY?
OBVIOUSLY, A POLITICAL PLOY,
POLITICAL GAME AND A
POLITICAL SHOW RATHER THAN
ACTUALLY NEGOTIATING A REAL
BORDER SECURITY DEAL AND AN
OPENING OF THE GOVERNMENT.
SHE WAS PERFECTLY HAPPY TO
TAKE A GOVERNMENT-FUNDED
PLANE AND A GOVERNMENT
FUNDED INTERCONTINENTAL TRIP
INSTEAD OF STAYING IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. AND
ACTUALLY DOING HER JOB.
KEEP IN MIND HER SEVEN DAY
ABSENCE FROM WASHINGTON,
THAT WOULD HAVE GUARANTEED
THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
FURLOUGHED, FEDERAL WORKERS.
THEY WOULD MISS THEIR NEXT
PAYCHECK IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IMPOSSIBLE TO GET IT.
SO SHE OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT FURLOUGHED
WORKERS.
SHE ONLY FEIGNS MORAL
OUTRAGE BECAUSE SHE HAD NO
INTENTION OF BEING THERE TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
TODAY ON THE HILL, THE HOUSE
MINORITY LEADER KEVIN
MCCARTHY BACKED UP THE
PRESIDENT'S LETTER
100 PERCENT, RIGHTLY.
SO TAKE A LOOK.
>> BEING SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE AND LEAVING THE
COUNTRY WITH A SHUTDOWN I
DON'T THINK IS APPROPRIATE.
ESPECIALLY THE SPEAKER
THINKS WE SHOULDN'T EVEN
HAVE THE STATE OF THE UNION?
I THINK THE BEST THING THAT
COULD HAPPEN AND EVERYBODY
COULD CALM A LITTLE BIT, GET
IN A ROOM TOGETHER AND PUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE FIRST
BEFORE THEIR TRAVELS AND
SOLVE THE PROBLEMS.
>> Tucker: REMEMBER AGAIN
AND AGAIN INCLUDING
YESTERDAY, DEMOCRATS REFUSED
TO GO TO THE WHITE HOUSE AT
THE PRESIDENT'S INVITATION,
REMEMBER THAT WEEKEND WHEN
THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS
STAYING ALL WEEKEND TO
NEGOTIATE WITH PELOSI AND
SCHUMER, THEY JUST SENT
THEIR AIDES.
THEY DIDN'T WANT A SOLUTION
TO THE PROBLEM.
SO, LEADER MCCARTHY IS
RIGHT.
SPEAKER PELOSI SHOULD BE
EMBARRASSED.
SHE CLAIMS THAT SHE CARES
ABOUT FURLOUGHED GOVERNMENT
WORKERS BUT SHE TRIED TO
POSTPONE, SHUTDOWN
NEGOTIATIONS SO SHE CAN TAKE
HER GOVERNMENT FUNDED
INTERNATIONAL TRIP.
SHE PRETENDS THAT HER FELLOW
DEMOCRATS ARE READY TO OPEN
THE GOVERNMENT IMMEDIATELY,
BUT ALLOWED DOZENS OF HER
COLLEAGUES TO TAKE THAT
LUXURIOUS, LOBBYIST-PAID
EXTRAVAGANT TROPICAL
VACATION TO PUERTO RICO.
THOSE ARE THE ONES WITH
LOBBYISTS, CORPORATE
EXECUTIVES.
GUESS WHAT?
YOU CAN SEE RIGHT THERE
SENATOR BOB MENENDEZ OF NEW
JERSEY NEXT TO THE WOMAN IN
THE BIKINI.
DOES THAT LOOK LIKE A MAN
THAT'S WORRIED ABOUT
FURLOUGHED EMPLOYEES OF THE
GOVERNMENT?
ALL EXPENSE PAID VACATION?
WELL THAT'S ONLY 10 DAYSED
INTO THE NEW CONGRESS.
VACATION PIED FOR 10 DAYS.
IN ONLY A DOLLAR FOR THE
WALL AND THE WALL IS
IMMORAL.
NANCY PELOSI PRETENDS THAT A
PARTIAL SHUTDOWN IS A MAJOR
CRISIS.
SOMEHOW MADE AMPLE TIME,
WHERE WAS SHE OVER THE
CHRISTMAS HOLIDAY?
VACATIONING IN HAWAII.
PRESIDENT URGED TO COME TO
THE WHITE HOUSE, MEET FACE
TO FACE TO NEGOTIATE.
HE STAYED IN WASHINGTON.
GAVE UP HIS VACATION.
SHE OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T CARE
ABOUT THE FURLOUGHED
WORKERS, AND SHE OBVIOUSLY
DOESN'T CARE ABOUT REOPENING
THE GOVERNMENT.
WHAT'S WORSE, SHE DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT THE ROOT CAUSE OF
THE SHUTDOWN.
WHICH IS BORDER SECURITY.
THIS IS LITERALLY FOR MANY
AMERICANS LIFE AND DEATH.
WHEN ANGEL MOMS AND DADS,
FAMILIES, YESTERDAY, THOSE
THAT LOST LOVED ONES AT THE
HANDS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
WENT TO HER OFFICE TO VISIT
WITH SPEAKER PELOSI, SHE WAS
IN THE OFFICE, SHE REFUSED
TO COME OUT AND EVEN MEET
THEM YESTERDAY.
AND THEN YOU HAVE GOT FAKE
JAKE TAPPER OVER AT FAKE
NEWS CNN.
IS HE RUSHING TO SPEAKER
PELOSI'S DEFENSE.
WHY?
I DON'T KNOW.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL
TELLS CNN THAT PELOSI AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
WELCOME TO FLY COMMERCIAL TO
AFGHANISTAN.
A REMARKABLE STATEMENT GIVEN
THAT THE PRESIDENT JUST
ANNOUNCED TO THE WORLD,
INCLUDING THE TALIBAN THAT
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE WAS
HEADED THERE.
>> Tucker: HE
>> Sean: ACTUALLY TOLD THEM
SHE IS NOT HEADING THERE.
NANCY PELOSI IS OBVIOUSLY
PAYING POLITICS WITH THE
SAFETY, THE SECURITY, OF ALL
AMERICANS, ALL BECAUSE SHE
JUST HATES DONALD TRUMP.
REMEMBER, DEMOCRATS SOUNDED
LIKE DONALD TRUMP FOUR YEARS
AGO.
SO, YEAH, IT MIGHT BE PRETTY
EASY TO MAKE THIS UP ON FAKE
NEWS CNN AND THEIR FRIENDS
IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO
CALL BORDER SECURITY THEY
WILL USE THE SAME PHRASE
MANUFACTURED CRISIS.
REALLY?
MANUFACTURED?
TELL THAT TO THE FACE OF
ANGEL MOMS AND DADS THAT
WERE ON THIS PROGRAM ON
FRIDAY ALL OF WHOM LOST
THEIR KIDS BECAUSE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND
SANCTUARY POLICIES.
YOU KNOW, THE FACTS PAINT A
VERY DIFFERENT PICTURE.
NOW, OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS, APPROXIMATELY 4,000
CRIMINAL ALIENS HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED FOR HOMICIDE.
30,000 FOR SEX CRIMES.
OVER 100,000 FOR VIOLENT
ASSAULTS.
IN JUST 2018 ALONE, 17,000
INDIVIDUALS WITH CRIMINAL
RECORDS WERE APPREHENDED
TRYING TO CROSS THE BORDER.
WE ALSO SAW 122% INCREASE IN
FENTANYL BEING SMUGGLED
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
AMERICANS ARE DYING EVERY
DAY FROM OVERDOSES, AT LEAST
300.
NOW, OVER THE LAST PHI
WEEKS, OVER 20,000 CHILDREN
WERE SMUGGLED OR TRAFFICKED
INTO THE UNITED STATES AND
AS YOU CAN SEE, FOR SO MANY,
THIS IS LITERALLY LIFE AND
DEATH.
ANGEL MOMS, YOU KNOW WHAT?
THEY ARE NEVER GOING TO SEE
THEIR KIDS AGAIN.
THAT'S PERMANENT SEPARATION.
REMEMBER THE DEMOCRATS?
THEY SEEM TO CARE ABOUT THE
ISSUE OF CHILD SEPARATION,
BUT ONLY WHEN THEY COULD
POLITICALLY BLUDGEON
PRESIDENT TRUMP WHO, IN THE
END, FIXED THAT PROBLEM, ONE
THAT HE INHERENTED FROM
THEIR BELOVED BARACK OBAMA,
THEY NEVER CRITICIZED HIM.
SOME VICTIMS WILL NEVER
RECOVER.
THIS DOESN'T PROTECT
DEMOCRATS SAFE AND SECURE ON
CAPITOL HILL LIVING IT UP OR
TAKING JUNKETS TO PUERTO
RICO.
MANY OF THEM HAVE NO PROBLEM
CALLING BORDER WALLS
ACTUALLY WALLS PROTECT BOTH
SIDES IMMORAL.
EASY TO PLAY POLITICS WHEN
YOU ARE NOT IMPACTED, YOU
ARE NOT AFFECTED.
IT HASN'T BEEN YOUR FAMILY.
AND THAT'S PROBABLY WHY
NANCY PELOSI'S DISTRICT HAS
NOW BECOME COVERED, LOOK AT
THIS.
WE SENT OUR CAMERAS FROM THE
HANNITY SHOW OVER TO NANCY
PELOSI'S DISTRICT.
WE SHOWED YOU LAST NIGHT.
HUMAN FECES, NEEDLES, WHILE
SHE SUSPECT THERE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., RAISING
MONEY, PLAYING POLITICS
WITHOUT TACKLING ANY SERIOUS
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
THIS IS WHAT HER DISTRICT
LOOKS LIKE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> NEEDLES AND BLOOD-STAINED
CLOTHING IN THE STREETS.
THAT CAN'T BE SAFE FOR
ANYONE.
>> I DO SEE A LOT OF NEEDLES
AND FECES EVERYWHERE.
AND THAT'S OBVIOUSLY ABOUT
DRUGS AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
>> KIND OF MAKES IT A TRAP
WHEN YOU WALK AROUND
NEEDLES, PLAYGROUND AND JUST
FECES EVERYWHERE.
THE SMELL OF IT ALL.
IT'S KIND --
>> -- YOU DEFINITELY HAVE TO
LOOK ON THE GROUND WHEN YOU
ARE WALKING.
IT'S BEEN -- IT'S DEFINITELY
AN UPTICK BECAUSE I HAVE
LIVED IN THIS CITY MORE THAN
30 YEARS.
IT'S PROBABLY THE WORSE I
HAVE SEEN IT.
>> Sean: PELOSI'S DISTRICT.
LIBERAL UTOPIA, PRETTY
DESPICABLE.
GIVEN THAT NANCY PELOSI'S
MASSIVE NET WORTH HER AND
HER OVER $30 MILLION.
THAT'S HER DISTRICT.
WELL, SHE COULD TAKE SOME OF
THAT MONEY, BUILD A HOMELESS
SHELTER IN HER DISTRICT SO
THAT HOMELESS PEOPLE MAYBE
CAN GET A BITE TO EAT.
MAYBE SLEEP, TAKE A SHOWER.
USE WHY NOT FIX THE PROBLEM.
HER DISTRICT.
OH, THAT'S RIGHT.
LIBERALS ARE ONLY GENEROUS
WITH OTHER PEOPLE'S MONEY.
FORGOT THAT SHE IS TOO BUSY
HATING DONALD TRUMP.
SHE IS TOO BUSY CALLING
WALLS TO PROTECT THIS
COUNTRY FROM 90% OF THE
HEROIN THAT COMES IN THROUGH
OUR SOUTHERN BORDER SHE
CALLED THE WALLS IMMORAL.
TONIGHT WE ARE SEEING SOME
FRACTURES FORM NOT GUILTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY INCLUDING
PELOSI'S SECOND IN COMMAND,
THAT'S MAJORITY LEADER STENY
HOYER.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE SUPPORTED THE
SUBSTANTIAL RESTRAINTS.
WE HAVE SUPPORTED FENCING.
WE HAVE SUPPORTED OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES.
SO, MY OWN VIEW IS THIS IS A
ISSUE OF MORALITY.
A WALL IS IMMORAL IF IT
TRIES TO IMPRISON PEOPLE
THAT SHOULDN'T BE
IMPRISONED.
A WALL THAT PROTECTS PEOPLE
IS NOT IMMORAL.
IT WORKS.
HAHN SEAN ACTUALLY GOOD TO
SEE A RARE MOMENT OF COMMON
ACCEPTS FROM THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
SADLY, THIS IS AN ANOMALY.
THIS IS PRETTY UNUSUAL.
THIS PARTY HAS NOW BEEN
HIJACKED BY THE MOST RADICAL
INDIVIDUALS, INCLUDING
DEVOUT SOCIALIST AND BIGOTED
ANTI-SEMITES AND LAWMAKERS
WHO WANT TO DISMANTLE,
LITERALLY, THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION, IT'S BEGINNING
TO BE A PRETTY SCARY
PICTURE.
AND YESTERDAY, WE SAW
PUBLICITY SEEKER FAR LEFT
FRESHMAN COMING WOMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
FILMING HERSELF STORMING
INTO THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL'S
OFFICE.
SHE IS DEMANDING THAT HE
REOPEN THE GOVERNMENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE'RE MARCHING OVER TO
MITCH McCONNELL'S OFFICE
TO SHOW THEM WHAT'S UP; IS
THAT RIGHT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> OKAY, GUYS.
WE WENT TO MITCH
MCCONNELL'S OFFICE WHERE WE
WENT TO THE SENATE CLOAK
ROOM.
#WHERE'S MITCH?
YOU CAN RUN BUT YOU CAN'T
HIDE.
>> Sean: WHEN OCASIO-CORTEZ
IS NOT BUSY PLOTTING NEXT
PUBLICITY STUNT TEACHING HER
FAR LESS MEDIA SAVVY
COLLEAGUES HOW TO DO THE
SAME.
YESTERDAY SHE HOSTED A
TWITTER 101 CLASS FOR HER
FELLOW DEMOCRATS BECAUSE, I
GUESS, THEY DON'T HAVE OTHER
PRESSING ISSUES TO DEAL
WITH.
SHE LEARNED TEACHING THEM
TWITTER.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET OWE
KAZMIERCZAKIO CORTEZ IS
FOZMIERCZAKIO CORTEZ IS
FOREIERCZAKIO CORTEZ IS
FOREOWRCZAKIO CORTEZ IS
FOREOWECZAKIO CORTEZ IS
FOREOWEKAAKIO CORTEZ IS
FOREOWEKAZMIO CORTEZ IS
FOREOWEKAZMIE CORTEZ IS
FOREOWEKAZMIERCORTEZ IS
FOREOWEKAZMIERCZATEZ IS
FOREOWEKAZMIERCZAKIZ IS
FOREOWEKAZMIERCZAKIO IS
FOREOW FAZMIERCZAKIO IS
FOREOW FORMIERCZAKIO IS
FOREOW FORGEERCZAKIO IS
FOREOW FORGETRCZAKIO IS
FOREOW FORGET OZAKIO IS
FOREOW FORGET OWEKIO IS
OCASIO-CORTEZ FLOATING TAX
RATE FOR AMERICANS.
DAN BONGINO HAD A SUGGESTION
WE WOULD LIKE TO ECHO ON
THIS PROGRAM.
OCASIO-CORTEZ LET HER LEAD
BY EXAMPLE.
SHE IS DONATE 70% OF HER
INCOME RIGHT NOW GIVE IT TO
THE GOVERNMENT.
AFTER ALL SALARY AS A
SITTING MEMBER OF CONGRESS
IS ACTUALLY TRIPLE MEDIAN
INCOME FOR AN ENTIRE FAMILY.
OCASIO-CORTEZ YOU WANT TO
TAKE EVERYONE ELSE'S MONEY
WILL YOU DONATE YOUR OWN.
PUT YOUR MONEY WHERE YOUR
MOUTH IS?
BETTER YET TAKE A TRIP, GO
TO CUBA OR VENEZUELA AND SEE
HOW YOUR SOCIALIST UTOPIA IS
WORKING IN ACTION.
THAT'S RIGHT.
YOU CAN'T BECAUSE OF THE
EXTREME CONDITIONS LIKE
CRIME AND CIVIL UNREST AND
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
NOW, EVEN RAN OUT OF TOILET
PAPER IN VENEZUELA LAST YEAR
BECAUSE OF SOCIALISM.
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY IS GOING
HUNGRY BECAUSE OF SOCIALISM.
THEY DON'T HAVE BASIC
MEDICAL SUPPLIES BECAUSE OF
SOCIALISM.
DO YOU REALLY THAT FOR
AMERICA?
HOW WELL DID THAT WORK OUT
FOR THE FORMER SOVIET UNION?
SADLY OCASIO-CORTEZ IS NOT
THE ONLY DEMOCRAT WITH THESE
RADICAL VIEWS.
ACTUALLY GETTING MUCH WORSE.
FOR EXAMPLE, MANY DEMOCRATS,
INCLUDING PRESIDENTIAL
CONTENDER, KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND, GET, THIS
ACTIVELY PARTICIPATING SIDE
BY SIDE WITH THE WELL-KNOWN
ANTI-SEMITE BY THE NAME OF
LINDA SARSOUR.
REMEMBER SARSOUR?
SHE HAS BEEN KNOWN TO PRAISE
AND PROMOTE SHARIA LAW.
WE KNOW WHAT SHARIA DOES FOR
WOMEN, GUYS, LESBIANS,
CHRISTIANS AND JEWS.
THAT'S RIGHT.
ALL PERSECUTED.
SHE RANT ABOUT SO-CALLED
ZIONISTS IN ISRAEL.
SHE SAID THAT IANHIRSI ALLI
DOESN'T DESERVE TO BE A
WOMAN AND HAVE HER ANATOMY
TAKEN AWAY.
GENTLE MUTILATION.
WHEN SHE WAS ACCUSED OF OF
ANTI-SEMITISM SHE BLAMED
QUOTE THE JEWISH MEDIA
THAT'S KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND'S
FRIEND SARSOUR HER AND
TAMIKA MOWERY ARE THE
FOUNDERS AND LEAD
ORGANIZATIONERS OF THIS
WEEKEND'S WOMEN'S MARCH IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
THEY ARE BOTH AVID FANS OF
THE BIGOTED HATE MONGER
ANTI-SEMITE RACIST LOUIS
FARRAKHAN.
MOWERY CALLING FARRAKHAN THE
GREATEST OF ALL TIME ON
TWITTER.
A REMINDER, HERE IS THE
PERSON OFTEN PRAISED BY THE
FOUNDERS OF THE WOMEN'S
MARCH COME UP THIS SATURDAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>>
THE JEWS DON'T LIKE
FARRAKHAN, SO THEY CALL ME
HITLER.
WELL, THAT'S A GOOD NAME.
HITLER WAS A VERY GREAT MAN.
THE SATANIC JEWS, THEY
CONTROL EVERYTHING AND
MOSTLY EVERYBODY.
>> THERE WERE MANY ISRAELIS
AND ZIONIST JEWS IN KEY
ROOMS IN THE 9/11 ATTACKS.
>> SEE, THE JEWS HAVE
CONTROL OVER THOSE AGENCIES
OF GOVERNMENT.
>> THE POWERFUL JEWS ARE MY
ENEMY.
>> Sean: ACCORDING TO RECENT
REPORTS THE NATION OF ISLAM
FOR SECURITY.
THE PURPOSE IS ON "THE VIEW"
THIS WEEK TAMIKA MALORY
REFUSED TO CONDEMN THIS HATE
PREACHER ANTI-SEMITE TAKE A
LOOK.
>> THE WOMEN'S MARCH UNSEE
GIVABLY CONDEMNS
ANTI-SEMITISM.
>> REMARKS ABOUT JEWISH
PEOPLE.
>> WE HAVE REPEATEDLY IN
STATEMENT AFTER STATEMENT
THIS YEAR WHICH ARE
AVAILABLE DIRECTLY ON OUR
WEBSITE FOR ANYONE TO READ.
>> I DON'T SPEAK FOR JEWISH
PEOPLE I THINK I'M JUST
CONFUSED.
IT GOES ON DEATH TO ISRAEL,
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> WE DID NOT MAKE THOSE
REMARKS.
>> YOU ARE ASSOCIATING WITH
A MAN WHO DOES PUBLICLY.
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY TO YOU
IS I DON'T AGREE WITH MANY
OF MR. FARRAKHAN'S
STATEMENTS.
>> SIMPLY ABOUT JEWISH
PEOPLE.
>> AS I SAID I DO NOT AGREE
WITH MANY OF MR. FARRAKHAN'S
STATEMENTS.
>> DO YOU CONDEMN THEM?
>> I DON'T AGREE WITH THESE
STATEMENTS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,.
>> YOU WON'T CONDEMN IT.
>> Sean: ORGANIZERS OF THE
WOMEN'S MARCH.
UNTIL RECENTLY THE DNC WAS
SPONSORING THIS MARCH COMING
UP SATURDAY.
THEY KNEW IT WAS BEING RUN
BY BIGOTED ANTI-SEMITES.
ONLY NOW THAT IT OUT IN THE
OPEN THE DNC HAS CANCELLED
PARTNERSHIP.
THEY WON'T ACKNOWLEDGE THE
REASON FOR THE CANCELLATION.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT LONG
HISTORY WITH FARRAKHAN.
REMEMBER NOT THAT LONG AGO
PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
RECENTLY APPEARING RIGHT
THERE ON STAGE WITH
FARRAKHAN.
OBAMA WAS PICTURED HANGING
OUT WITH THIS HATE PREACHER
JUST PRIOR TO HIS TIME AS
PRESIDENT.
BY THE WAY, THEY HID THIS
PICTURE FROM YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE FOR 8 YEARS.
AND SADLY, THE DEMOCRATS'
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH
ANTI-SEMITISM IT DOESN'T
STOP THERE YOU HAVE FRESHMAN
CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR IS ALSO A
KNOWN ANTI-SEMITE ONCE
CALLED ISRAEL APARTHEID
STATE AND THAT'S JUST THE
TIP OF THE.
WATCH.
THIS ISRAEL HIP ADVERTISE
THE WORLD ALLAH AWAKEN THE
PEOPLE AND SEE THE EVIL
TOOTION OF ISRAEL.
COMMENTED A LOT SINCE THEN.
TRYING TO EXPLAIN WHAT YOU
MEANT BY THAT.
AND I WONDER JUST WHAT YOUR
MESSAGE IS THIS MORNING AS
THE FIRST ON OUR GAME
CHANGER SERIES TO JEWISH
AMERICANS WHO FIND THAT
DEEPLY OFFENSIVE.
>> OH, THAT'S REALLY
REGRETTABLE WAY OF
EXPRESSING THAT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MY COMMENTS
WOULD BE OFFENSIVE TO JEWISH
AMERICANS.
>> Sean: YOUR NEW RADICAL
EXTREME DEMOCRATIC SOCIALIST
PARTY IN AMERICA PELOSI,
CHUCK SCHUMER, ARE YOU PROUD
TO CALL THIS ANTI-SEMITIC
DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUE OF YOURS
AND WHEN CONGRESSWOMAN OMAR
IS NOT TRASHING ISRAEL, SHE
IS ATTACKING REPUBLICAN
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
BECAUSE OF HIS SUPPORT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE SHE
TWEETED QUOTE:  THEY GOT TO
HIM.
IS HE COMPROMISED.
AND ON CNN, SHE HAD A HARD
TIME EXPLAINING HER
DISGUSTING ALLEGATIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> HE IS SOMEHOW
COMPROMISED.
NO LONGER STAND UP FOR THE
TRUTH.
TO MAKE SURE THAT HE IS
FIGHTING TO PROTECT THE OATH
THAT HE TOOK IN SERVING THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> BUT THAT'S QUITE A CHARGE
TO MAKE.
YOU SAY YOU ARE PRETTY SURE
BASED ON WHAT EVIDENCE?
WHAT FACT?
THAT'S REMARKABLE COMMENT TO
MAKE ABOUT A SITTING U.S.
SENATOR?
>> THE EVIDENCE REALLY IS
PRESENT -- BEING PRESENTED
TO US IN THE WAY HE IS
BEHAVING.
>> AGAIN, BASED ON WHAT
EVIDENCE, CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> MY TWEET WAS JUST AN
OPINION BASED ON WHAT I
BELIEVE TO BE VISIBLE TO ME.
>> Sean: WELL, IS NANCY
PELOSI HAPPY WITH THIS
RADICAL PARTY OF HERS AND
CONSPIRACY THEORIES?
THIS PARTY IS NOW A
DISASTER.
AMERICA BETTER WAKE UP
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS DO NOT
HAVE YOUR BEST INTEREST IN
MIND.
NOW WE TURN OUT TO OUR
HANNITY WATCH ON OUR DEEP
STATE TONIGHT.
WE REPORTED LAST NIGHT JOHN
SULLIVAN AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL BRUCE
OHR KNITTING IN ADMITTING IN
CONGRESSIONAL TESTIMONY THAT
HE WARNED FBI BRASS AND DOJ
BRASS THAT THAT DIRTY TRUMP
DOSSIER WAS IN FACT
POLITICAL OPPOSITION BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC.
AND THAT THE DOCUMENT WAS
LIKELY TAINTED WITH AN ANTI
TRUMP BIAS BECAUSE HAD A
PERSONAL ANIMUS AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
IT WAS STILL SUBMITTED
MONTHS LATER TO THE FISA
COURT AS THE BULK OF
INFORMATION DESPITE NEVER
BEING VERIFIED OR
CORROBORATED.
SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
OUR OWN GREGG JARRETT
EXPLAINS IT IN A NEW COLUMN
TONIGHT.
MUELLER'S PROSECUTORS KNEW
THAT THE RUSSIAN LIES AND
THES TO YEA
THE DTO YEA
THE DOS YEA
THE DOSSIEA
THE DOSSIER WAS A PRODUCT OF
BIAS AND DECEPTION.
JAMES COMEY, SALLY YATES,
ROD ROSENSTEIN AND ALL THE
OTHERS APPEARED TO HAVE MADE
A CONSCIOUS DECISION TO MAKE
MATERIALLY FALSE STATEMENTS
AND LIE AND COMMIT A FRAUD
ON THE FISA COURT.
THIS MUST BE INVESTIGATED
AND HANDLED.
THE RULE OF LAW MUST
PREVAIL.
AND ACTIVELY CONCEALING
PERTINENT INFORMATION AND
FAILING TO DISCLOSE THOSE
JUDGES THAT ANY OF THIS IN
THE FISA APPLICATION ON
CARTER PAGE.
THEY PRESENTED IT AS FULL
AND TRUTHFUL AND THEY KNEW
THE EXACT OPPOSITE.
THEY ABUSE THE FISA WARRANT
PROCESS THAT IS IN VIOLATION
OF AMERICA'S CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
AND IT UNDERMINES A DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
NOW, REMEMBER, JAMES COMEY
TOLD THE PRESIDENT THE
DOCUMENT WAS UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS.
WELL, THAT WAS IN JANUARY OF
2017.
HE SIGNED OFF ON IT AS
ACCURATE IN OCTOBER OF 2016.
AND WILLIAM BARR, ONCE YOU
ARE CONFIRMED AS THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, YOU MUST